patrick corbin ready to go nationals in
the all home white and in steps the man
who leads the major leagues and rbis
with a chance to get rbi number 40 or
more right here
right side base hit a third one to the
right side and the orioles on top as
hayes scores
galvez
gets to second another rbi and the
orioles take a one nothing lead in the
first inning two on for anthony
santander ahead 3-0 the pitch on the way
he swings and grounds it through the
left side for a single galvez turns
third he's headed to the plate rbi base
knock for zontander it's two nothing
orioles in the first inning so two down
mancini on third base
and michael franco at the plate
the 1-0
there he swings laces it down the right
field line he'll bring in a run mancini
comes around franco digging for second
throw comes in on one bounce it's past
turner
it gets out to third base where it's
backed up by castro franco he does come
through this time bringing home mancini
the orioles a three run first inning and
franco needed that
matt harvey as we mentioned three-game
losing streak trying to end it so here's
josh bell runner in scoring position one
out and now the set of the pitch swing
in a line drive to right santander over
to his right can't get there gets it on
the backhand turner held up now around
third being waved home and he'll score
easily as santander plays it into second
base
josh bell has now hit in eight of his
last 10 games 12 out of his last 32
drives in his 18th run of the year
and the nationals are on the board with
one out of the bottom of the first it's
the orioles three of the nationals one
well that's big to answer the orioles
beginning with at least one run
and here's schwarber up there swinging
high fly ball deep right center
c
u
later
and this game immediately is tied up
bang
soon goes schwarber
404 feet the estimated distance
and just like that
four batters into the bottom of the
first three runs home it's the nationals
three in the orioles three and avila
from the left side matt harvey to the
belt the kick in the pitch and avila
swings and lines it to right down the
line a fair ball into the corner rolls
right to the bullpen fence near the foul
pole harrison around third comes in to
score santander gets it in towards
second
it's a double for avila his third of the
year he drives in his fourth run and the
nationals with four runs home at the
bottom of the first now lead for the
first time it's washington four in
baltimore three
as michael franco digs in
against patrick corbin second and third
one out
the one one and this one sky in the air
center field stevenson towards the right
center field gap he makes the catch
tagging it third is mancini here's the
throw it'll be cut off play at third
base and safe is santander as he gets
the third and mancini scores
so a very
productive sacrifice fly from michael
franco
and this game is tied up at four
so then that's four in the orioles four
and here's turner with a chance
the one to turner swinging a fly ball
right center field deep back on this one
is hayes to the warning track he's there
and he makes the catch both runners will
tag avila scores stevenson to third and
the nationals are back in front
they lead it five to four as turner gets
a sac fly and rbi number 25 and with the
wind
just missed getting that ball up on the
wall
and there is a line drive to right
off the bat of josh harrison
who's having an amazing weekend
he's now five out of nine
and on base for the sixth time
three two runners going and the bases
are loaded
another excellent at bet by alex sevilla
and the gnats
are trying to make the error hurt
that freddie galvez committed on the
high throw and now it's up to andrew
stevenson now the base is loaded with
two out after the walk to avila and
andrew stevens into the plate runners
will be on the move again castro from
third harrison from second avila from
first the 3-2 pitch is low ball four
castro trotting home with run number six
it's the national six in the orioles
four
a bases loaded walk for andrew stevenson
gets his ninth rbi of the year
seven pitches five foul balls
corbin one two pitch there's another one
finally throws a strike
and
mount castle races in to grab it to end
the inning
that's at another run
and cash in some walks and they lead at
6-4
[Music]
and if he doesn't get valeka maybe this
could be his last hitter
or it could be another double play ball
the third of the day for patrick corbin
four six three two now
then he hits for power two long sack fly
last time
trey one for two i'm sorry trade two for
three
19th
multi-hit game of the year
[Music]
[Applause]
galves mancini and santander in the
oriole seven
it well right field
and it's down for extra bases
soto up with it galvez hustling into
second
and freddy's got a lead off double his
second hit of the game
so galvez now at third with nobody out
nationals will play the infield back
with that two-run 6-4 lead
full count to the right side
bell hustles over gets the out
train mancini with an rbi
and it's a 6'5 game
oh
he pulled the string on him
if 88 slider is pulling the string
10 miles an hour quicker is the fastball
he'll get a call near the outside edge
outcastle unhappy chris conroy rings him
up
swing and a mess
red hand is back
hudson in hand every day and the
nationals sweep the orioles winning six
to five